go green go screw yourself sure the
nation is now less safe more babies will
be murdered abroad but thanks to Obama
stringent new auto emission policies
you'll no longer be needing that SPF 30
the global warming alarmists are out in
flock you've seen these people have you
been outside it's mild and sunny in the
middle of winter proof global warming
for you we had a different word for it
as a kid what was it oh yeah a nice day
hey I was raised in Quebec we could use
a little more global warming where I'm
from we buy Hummers just to leave them
running I'm not quite sure what the
agenda is anymore it's not global
warming its climate change now I'm being
told that we're running out of water
if that's so I've made a doozy because I
left my faucet on for two weeks straight
and account of the ice caps melting
listen to buy into these policies you
have to believe four things one that the
earth is warming dose that humans are
the cause of it three that that will
have catastrophic results and four you
have to believe the only way to fix it
is to remove personal freedom and
relinquish that control to the
government folks it's no secret that the
government's never been efficient with
money so why would you want to give them
more power that's like giving your kid a
cookie for crapping in your jewelry box
do you know what really happens when a
polar bear stops paddling they float
we've all seen these pictures
celebrities are pushing to make our
children sympathetic to their global
warming cause cute cuddly little
woodland creatures clinging to an
iceberg in an attempt to get them to
recycle in a spirit of full disclosure
let's show the kids that same bear two
minutes later tearing apart a baby see a
limb from limb tossing his lower
intestines across the Alaskan tundra
then we can have a PSA of me spraying
said bear with an aerosol can from my
nitro imbued Range Rover
environmentalist can you please stop
targeting children I mean aren't there
more pressing issues to teach them let's
see save the great white shark or
pedophile awareness teach these kids to
not talk to strangers stay away from
drugs don't play with blasting caps
something important let me tell you
Captain Planet ruined my childhood I
refuse to wear Park on my mom had bought
me an account of that blue molded
leotard wearing fruitcake urging me not
to wear fur I had to wear my mom's old
puffy jacket instead I want those three
years of my life
worst part is that hood turned out to be
nothing more than polyester trim listen
the Earth's atmosphere is less than
point zero four percent carbon dioxide
and humans account for very little of
that to think that the world is warming
because of your Jeep Cherokee is absurd
that would be like having a problem with
your car and looking to the rear left
hubcap bolt for the answer hey don't you
think we should check out the engine
first no no I'm pretty sure it's the
left bolt to put it in context all human
carbon emissions don't even amount to a
fraction of that of cow flatulence
you've heard directly Florida might be
flooded on account of cow farts I'm
gonna do my part take my SUV to the
nearest pasture and mow down a whole
herd listen I'm no brilliant scientist
so I've listed a few sources of people
who can explain this much better than I
I will say this if you accept global
warming as absolute scientific fact and
something alarming enough to relinquish
our personal freedom so the government
as well as indoctrinate our children
well then you've just been drinking so
much of it you're starting to look like
the kool-aid guy oh yeah